um
um
microphone check 10 9.
i don't know
thank you
um
oh
is
i'm walking around
i mean
i feel it today
another victory
we need more
i'm
yeah
uh
just
uh
hello everyone we just had a nice
victory on the floor of the house
for hr8 now we're moving on to hr 40
1446 so here we are
one year ago today the world health
organization declared
the coronavirus a coven 19
a pandemic a pandemic
about on that day by then a thousand
americans had been infected
about 38 had died from the pandemic
here we are a year later
as we observe that sad
moment and everything that has ensued
from them
with over 500 000 americans
who have died around 30 million have
become infected
and again our hearts are broken
for them they're fat for their families
and for all of those
who are affected by the coronavirus
but we also today
are celebrating legislation that will
make a tremendous difference
president biden's american rescue plan
is a plan to crush the virus
and to save lives and livelihood of the
american people
it is historic it is monumental it is
consequential
uh and i said it's probably the most
consequential legislation
most of us will ever many of us will
ever vote for in the congress i put it
on the par with the affordable care act
as having serious consequences for the
well-being of the american people
dividing plan will make an immediate
difference in people's lives
injecting vaccine into their arms
money into their pockets children going
back into school
safely and people going to work
safely uh so it is
it's just remarkable it's remarkable
legislation
unfortunately republicans as i say
you know both know and take the dough
you see already some of them claiming oh
this is a good thing or that's a good
thing but they couldn't
give it a vote anyway enough of them i
talked about children in school when i
talked about this legislation yesterday
i talked about it in terms of america's
children
children are my why why i went from
housewife to
house speaker because of the children
that one in five children in america
lives in poverty as a mother of five i
couldn't abide
that and wanted to make a difference in
public policy one in five goes to sleep
hungry
at night hungry at night that was even
before the colonia virus
and i've always said that the three most
important issues facing the congress are
our children
our children our children their health
their education
the economic security of their families
including the pension security for their
grandparents
and a environment in which they can
thrive
safely world at peace in which they can
reach their fulfillment
well the first three of those their
health their education
and the economic security of their
families was very much
affected by the biden american rescue
plan we're very proud of what it does
for children their health their
education and the economic security of
their families
today on the floor we go to that fourth
place
a safe environment which our children
can thrive by passing the background
check legislation
it's hard to imagine legislation being
more popular than the rescue plan
75 percent whatever this legislation
background checks closer to 90 percent
bipartisan support across the country
receiving the support of gun owners
hunters and the rest
they've all had to do a background check
why shouldn't others
our chairman of the task force mike
thompson is is a hunter
is a veteran and is a gun owner and he
has
had again protective of the first
amendment rights of gun owners
but also protective of the survival of
our children
so i see this issue through the eyes of
our children
i tell my colleagues of stories when i
go to like a child care center
in my district a few years several years
ago
were playing on the floor with stuff and
all of a sudden
a balloon burst and the kids yell
drop four-year-old children yelling drop
and that is not unusual in certain
communities what are we doing to them
our children as
senator murphy this morning in our press
conference talked about what it does
uh to to the well-being of children to
live in a
dangerous atmosphere and so we all know
about the children in newtown and i
thought
for sure we would get gun violence
legislation gun violence prevention
legislation passed then but
they said no time and time again
florida nevada you name it
all over the country so here we are with
this legislation and we're very
optimistic
that with 90 support in the public and
with a public awareness
uh again the drum beat created by the
people out there the survivors of gun
violence we told them we're not
resting until we get this job done and
today we're taking
a giant a step in that direction
for the children and as i say about
these members of congress
there's no if you are afraid to vote
for gun violence prevention because of
your political survival
understand this the political survival
of none of us
is more important than the survival of
our children
and the fear that they have of this
so as i've said about the uh the um
uh rescue package
how great it was uh when we sent it over
to
the senate and a package that had been
uh negotiated
there were some changes not much so that
we could receive it back
in terms of the essence of the bill
but one important part of it that did
not survive the
bird rule or the bird lady or whatever
it is over there
was the minimum wage and we will persist
with the minimum wage now what i want
you to understand is because
so many times you hear people say well
i'm for a ten dollar
minimum wage or i'm for an 11 minimum
wage
well understand what the fight for 15
has been all about
it's about a fight for 15 where by 2025
people would arrive at 15
so if you're for a 10 raising the
minimum wage now
it's only 9 50 and this year 2021
11.2022
1250 and 2023
20 of 14.2024 and finally
15 dollars in 2025. i've been fighting
for the fight for 15
for a number of years quite frankly i
think it should be higher but this
is the fight that we are in
so if you think it's okay to have a 10
minimum wage
we don't even get there this year
we don't even get there this year when
we passed the bill
in 2007 it was one of the first bills we
passed the first 100 hours
of the new uh democratic majority
it was one of our fight uh uh
six for six you know the six row six
that we had
six bills we passed it we sent it to the
senate
it didn't make it there but we put it in
an appropriations bill
and it passed first we passed it and
president bush vetoed it
but then we put in appropriations bill
and then it was passed and signed
by the president so it was a fight then
for seven dollars and 25 cents really
um and um i tell the story that when we
when we went outside to celebrate
senator kennedy
was the leader of it as a chairman of
the health committee in the senate
he came to the podium and he said you
know what we have to do now
we have to raise the minimum wage
because he knew that 725 wasn't even
enough then but here it is 9
15. can you live on 950
family of four both parents making the
minimum wage
725 still under the poverty line
and by the way a low substandard minimum
wage
is corporate welfare it is subsidizing
the private sector not to reward work
and how do we subsidize it medicaid
food uh assistance
housing assistance and the rest so the
taxpayer
is subsidizing the low minimum wage
for the private sector fortunately not
everybody in the private sector thinks
that way
and they respect the dignity of work and
many of them
have come closer to a
not even a living wage but at least a
higher
minimum wage so this is again that just
we're not giving up on that we're not
giving up
on gun violence prevention we've told
the survivors
again and again we're not going away we
will persist
until the law is changed
and we have safety for our children so
again this is a hopeful time and
i want to praise of course senator
schumer
leader schumer for his uh
leadership and sending us back a bill
that we did not have to amend or go to
conference on because it
resembled enough what we had sent over
there
except for the minimum wage and we'll
find a path on that
so again
one year ago declared a pandemic
in the course of that time declared a
hoax all the rest of that
avoiding science and the rest
and now truly an attempt
to crush the virus any questions
yes okay yeah
and then all right gary so
when you have been focused on covet the
republicans have been talking about
immigration when you were focused on the
voting rights act they were talking
about immigration
today you're talking about fight for 15
today they're talking about immigration
i'm wondering if house democrats or you
guys
why are you why are we not seeing the
same thing is this a distraction on
their part
is it a mistake for house democrats to
not include immigration elements earlier
in the agenda
i'm just trying to swear how these two
parties are talking about
such different things as the issue right
now well i guess their doctor zeus
approach didn't work for them
so now they've had to change the subject
but we do not
prioritize our values and how we can get
make a difference in the lives of the
american people
to be attuned to the bankruptcy of ideas
that the republicans have no there was
no mistake
the bill is except for the minimum a
minimum wage
again certain tweaks here and there
which were not
consequential the bill is what we all
agree to
as the priorities to save lives and
livelihoods
shots in the arm money in the pockets
kids in the school safely and workers
back in their jobs
yes sir madam speaker i just want to ask
you about the surge of unaccompanied
minors at the southern border
the fine administration has acknowledged
that the humanitarian
effort that they have may be an
incentive for them to come
what would you like to see done out
there
well i i don't know i i haven't heard
them say that that would be an incentive
i do think what they are doing is
talking to regional governments to say
keep them home as well as if they have
a a case for
refugee status or asylum seekers to have
that adjudicated
in the cut have those interviews happen
in the country
of origin but for those who are
coming uh they have a humane uh policy
about how they
as quickly as possible and it takes time
because you want to do it right
can and can get them uh situated in
with with family member or safe place
for them to be
and it will be nothing like what we saw
in the trump administration of pbs being
snatched from the arms of their parents
uh to me as a mom and a grandmother that
to me is like the most
vile with stiff competition from the
trump administration but one of the most
vile things they did
so i think that the uh i i
trust uh the biden administration's
policy to be based on humanitarian
uh and love of children rather than
political points or red meat for their
big
for their republican base now let me
just say one thing about
asylum seekers four years ago
around now the the president then
president
uh put a ban a muslim ban in place
um the same women who marched
the day after the inauguration saw the
power of their presence
and many of them marched to the airports
and to other
venues to protest the muslim ban
but not only them they were an example
to others
and you saw an outpouring of disapproval
of what the president was doing we then
had a
a a session here it couldn't be a
hearing because we were in the minority
but we had a rump meeting
about asylum seekers and an opposition
to the muslim ban we had the military
come and say how could they do this
we promised our interpreters and others
who helped us in iraq and afghanistan
who were muslim
that they could come to the united
states and this is hurting our
security we had our diplomats maybe a
thousand signed a letter
which was un usual that many uh but them
to testify about how this was bad for
our national security
from a diplomatic standpoint we had
a economist saying this is bad for our
economy
in terms of the intellectual resources
that we were depriving our country but
why i bring it up
is we had a representative a
representative of the
american evangelicals association
or the association of american evangel
and what he
said at that meeting that i think
everybody should continue to remember
because the evangelicals have been
really good
on immigration and on asylum seekers and
refugees
he said the united states
refugee resettlement program
is the crown jewel of american
humanitarianism
and that was at a time when the
administration was preparing to reduce
the number that we received
while encouraging other countries to
take other asylum seekers
so it is um it is
you know it's a a value decision that we
have to make and i
i think the difference between this
administration one before
is great in terms of how we
meet the needs of these children placing
them
as much as possible with family but in
other safe
homes and in the meantime to have uh
a humanitarian uh reception for them
wherever they are
it is a it's a big it's a big one i'll
just tell you this one more thing
i took a group as a before covert so it
was
the last trip that i was able to take to
central america to the northern triangle
honduras guatemala
and el salvador to see what was
happening there in terms of
dangerous situations that people were
escaping and and
that was the reason why they would risk
crossing a desert because they would die
if they stayed home
and their children as well uh what were
the economic situation what what
was it that we could help them with to
keep
people home because people really
generally do like to stay home
one of the things that was interesting
on that trip
was that many a number of the people who
were leaving for economic reasons
were farmers because the the
drought had caused such a severe
situation
in the northern triangle they could no
longer farm
it was what was arable before was no
longer arable
again a climate issue a climate
issue and so there are all kinds of ways
that we can
help people be successful at uh
or comfortable at least at home rather
than coming to the united states but to
recognize
there are many reasons why they do some
because of the dangerous situation to
their lives and we could spend all day
going on chapter and verse of all the
young people we met
and how they feared for their lives in
the communities they were
they were in yes sir madam speaker um
since the president is understood
meeting with lawmakers from both parties
on
infrastructure uh it seems like that may
be the next legislative agenda item
for the biden administration curious
your thoughts on the size and scope
of a deal considering that the 1.9
trillion dollar covet relief bill got
zero republican votes in congress yeah
well i thank you for the question it's
one of my favorite subjects
uh the the infrastructure
we like to call it bob's legislation
is uh it's so important because it's
about
jobs it's about uh quality of life for
people when we have
better roads and transit systems in the
rest to have them spend less time in
their cars
more time at home a 45-minute ride which
should be a
20 or 15 minute ride should that's a
quality of life
issue what that means in terms of clean
air
for our children and grandchildren to
breathe so it's a
quality of life issue in many respects
in terms of time but also
in times of clean air again a jobs jobs
jobs issue
not only in the construction of these
projects
but also the commerce it prove it uh
enables to happen
and in farm country where uh time is
important in terms of product
uh produce from from field to or from
farm to market and the rest
time time time so the list goes on and
on
and it's not just roads and bridges uh
and mass transit and high speed railroad
it's also about water systems some of
the water systems
that we have now 100 over 100 years old
i've been saying this for 10 years so
they're over 110 years old they're made
of brick and wood
we really need to address the water
systems in our country and
one of my colleagues a congresswoman
to leave has been on this case uh in
terms of
safe water uh for our children all over
the country as as has dan kildee
representing
uh flint michigan and the rest so it's
about that but it's also about
infrastructure
we see in all of this uh telemedicine
uh distance learning commerce
through the internet family interactions
and the rest so that
that piece of intersect infrastructure
which might not have been one we had 20
years ago
is important now so and
for these and other reasons schools
housing all that
but remember this this has always been
bipartisan for us
and the many deca in the years i've been
in congress three decades
it's always been bipartisan the only
time they interfered with that is when
president obama presented his plan and
they cut it back but we still got
something but not
as much as was needed by the
american society of civil engineers
we're way behind where we should be
in terms of building the infrastructure
so i would hope it would because it'll
be in their districts
again they'll vote no and take the doe
show up at the ribbon cutting and the
rest
uh so hopefully they will be an
intellectual resource
as well as to what are the uh priorities
in their region what has the support of
the communities and the rest
uh and whether it's a water project or
whatever
infrastructure it is it's very popular
with the american people
and the problem we had the president uh
trump always said during the campaign
his you know 16 campaign and since he
for a long time he always talked about
infrastructure i didn't have a
conversation with him for the first
year and a half say that he was in
office that infrastructure was not
a part of the conversation it's just
when it came time to pay for it that he
stormed out the door
uh but but we'll have to pay for some of
it we'll have to find ways to cover
with fees etc that's all a discussion
that has to take place now
but there's no question the most
expensive maintenance
of our infrastructure is no maintenance
it only just gets worse
and so we see this as a tremendous
opportunity
all across america creating jobs
promoting commerce cleaning the air
improving quality of life and we hope
that it will be bipartisan
international women's week come on woman
what do you got for the other
[Music]
security threats that that was um
something that was in the house
so the security threats were now in the
house i'm wondering what happens you
have
i have no i've never i've said that that
has been alleged i have never made any
characterization of that that remains
for the fbi and others to investigate
what do you got chad
chad thank you so much so yesterday the
house administration committee voted to
continue its inquiry
into the iowa second congressional
district here could you see a scenario
depending on what they find in their
probe of
unseating the current number and seating
hard if it came to them
you know tech chad is always the
the hypothetical could you see a
scenario
we don't do press conferences on can you
see a scenario
they have i respect the work of the
committee i did
see as you saw in the press uh what they
uh decided to uh uh and and they were
following my
as i read it the uh requirements of the
law
as to how you go forward and how you go
forward is the path you're on
and uh and we'll see that where that
takes us yeah but there could be a
scenario to that extent yes
on the minimum
takes all this time to get to 15 an
hour carry this around in your head
and think of how you could live on this
put food on the table and have the
dignity of your work
respected thank you all
smackdown
problems